you know
this is an insane film i'm sure you're
hearing that this is such an incredible
cinematic experience and there you are
in the air with tom and i said i think
you said it best because you kept saying
oh [ __ ]
like that's exactly what this film is
you feel that ocean
i know i mean
the amount of times i said that in
training it was
yeah
it's legit has it sunk in you're part of
this a pinch me moment that you're with
tom cruise
in a plane i know like not i mean not
really i think honestly kind of doing
these interviews and stuff that's that's
really where we get to
experience this through the eyes of
people that really had had no idea what
to expect yeah so i just feel
i mean yeah yeah it's interesting
looking at the poster and seeing tom as
a fan but then but having him as a
friend and having him you know been a
mentor on this film for all of us is
just really really special i love that
you said he's a friend because i
understand that way back you went to his
place for a chemistry test and to see if
you wanted to be part of this what
convinced you to say yes i'm going to
take this role on ah
i mean i
it to be fair the thing that i
really was just kind of to me the only
negative of it was just being a part of
something that you really know is going
to be so huge
and
that's something i don't take lightly i
mean i it's something there's definitely
something i was thinking about a lot but
i mean to work with
you know tom and jerry bruckheimer and
to work with joe since again it really i
mean it was it wasn't that hard of a
decision i did and i'm so glad i i i'm
doing it because it was a it was a big
big thing for me let's talk about the
training you call it the tom cruise boot
camp yeah you went through a lot would
you do it again and was there a moment
that you will never forget
i would i would do it again
um
yeah of course i'll do it again yeah
well i think for
as far as like building camaraderie
within a cast i think collective
suffering is probably one of the
quickest ways to get to know strangers
it really is
um
i mean we really were just thrown in the
deep end on this thing yeah so it was
really
really unique but i mean the first time
we saw tom put his maverick helmet on
thousand moment and even just seeing him
like walk down you know uh you know the
tarmac and
you know or come off a jet was just so
many moments that just seemed pretty
surreal you just kept watching him right
one time
actually one time i was filming a scene
and
this pilot was was coming back
and um you know he's kind of rolling the
jet in and he was i think it was the
guys who were working on it were just
nonchalantly blasting um the top gun
soundtrack as monica and i are filming a
scene
and i just look right in the lens
because i'm like we have to
cut because these guys are just blasting
the soundtrack in the middle of it who
puked the most i mean that that's
vigorous training to hit some of those
g's i'm not gonna you could say someone
told me a story i will say i mean to say
it i will say
that just say it uh myself monica and
jay
never
never lost it so you can
do the math what do you say
yeah it was clamoring it was glenn yeah
shoots everywhere all the time he said
some story about apostles
you know 36 years since the original and
he was given the name maverick now that
you know him and you call him a friend
what's the nickname you would give tom
i mean we just call him tc yeah i think
that's i think that's uh
you know that's that's a good one yeah
congratulations i'm so happy for you i
appreciate it you what you guys have
done for the fans is just
thank you so much
you